[Música]
en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología y debido a la
emergencia que vivimos a causa de la
pandemia de kobe 19 nos adaptamos desde
nuestros hogares para llevarles toda la
información
-soy valentina torres sánchez gracias
por acompañarme en esta ocasión vamos a
iniciar en hong kong porque científicos
de este país anunciaron lo que llamaron
el primer caso de reinfección de kobe 19
probado o documentado en el mundo
por el caso que reportamos es el primero
documentado de laboratorio de una
reinfección de joven 19
el paciente es un hombre de 33 años que
fue diagnosticado por primera vez en
marzo como un contagio local en hong
kong
posteriormente en agosto cuatro meses y
medio después cuando volvió a hong kong
desde españa pasando por londres fue
diagnosticado con un segundo contagio de
kobe 19 años
en principio se pensó que el hombre
podría ser lo que se denomina un
portador
del virus y haber mantenido el agente
dentro de su organismo todo este tiempo
no obstante los investigadores con con
heces revelaron que las secuencias
genéticas del virus son diferentes es
decir distintas cepas del mismo virus
tras conocerse esta noticia expertos de
países como bélgica y países bajos
informaron que en cada una de estas
naciones se han registrado al menos un
caso de reinfección porque es tan
importante esta noticia algo de lo que
se ha estudiado fuertemente hasta el
momento es si una persona que ya
contrajo el virus desarrolla inmunidad
para no volver a contagiarse éstos
recontar yos significarían que aunque si
hay anticuerpos que se desarrollan tras
tener como y 19 las defensas pueden
disminuir considerablemente con el pasar
de unos pocos meses
es muy importante entender lo que esto
significa en términos de inmunidad y por
eso tenemos a tantos grupos de
investigación rastreando a las personas
midiendo los anticuerpos tratando de
entender cuánto dura la protección
inmune la protección inmune natural y se
debería entender que no es la misma que
provee una
vamos ahora hasta américa latina para
conocer otras de las iniciativas que ha
implementado la región para luchar
contra la pandemia en méxico un grupo de
expertos creó un ventilador automático
de emergencia diseñado producido y
aprobado en el país se llama bsc está
2012 y funciona con un tanque de oxígeno
normalmente nos tardamos años es decir
un dispositivo clase 3 se desarrolló
típicamente de 4 a 5 6 años de trabajo
nosotros teníamos la carrera del tiempo
encima porque tuvimos que realizarlo en
tan solo 10 semanas es ideal para los
hospitales que se instalaron
improvisados dado que no tendrían que
hacer toda la infraestructura de los
gases medicinales que es algo que cuesta
tiempo dinero sí seguro esfuerzo
continuamos en latinoamérica y vamos a
colombia porque este país cuenta con un
examen estatal que evalúa la calidad de
la educación comúnmente se conoce como
pruebas icfes y este año por primera vez
se aplicó de manera virtual más de 70
mil estudiantes presentaron el examen
desde sus casas
con los responsables de la iniciativa el
control de la prueba se realizó gracias
a un sistema de inteligencia artificial
que permitió determinar que los jóvenes
desarrollarán el examen adecuadamente
como un hecho sin precedentes para la
evaluación de la educación en el país
el icfes asumió el reto de aplicar por
primera vez un examen de estado
electrónico y en casa más de 72 mil
estudiantes terminaron
satisfactoriamente las pruebas a verte y
te realizada el primero 22 y 23 de
agosto se trata de un gran logro para el
sector educativo el haber llevado un
examen de estado hasta la casa de miles
de colombianos priorizando su salud y
garantizando la supervisión efectiva
continuamos en dinamarca porque una
joven diseñó un ingenioso tapabocas que
se limpia sólo utilizando luz
ultravioleta sabemos que esta tecnología
se está utilizando para desinfectar
espacios como hospitales aviones y
vehículos de transporte público pero
este nuevo uso ha sido considerado
revolucionario la mascarilla tiene óxido
de metal impreso en la tela y al entrar
en contacto con la luz ultravioleta
los virus presentes en ese material
quedan inactivos por lo que el tapabocas
puede ser reutilizado para la
responsable de esta idea el uso de una
mascarilla que no se deseche después de
una sola apuesta es clave para cuidar el
medio ambiente
las máscaras desechables ya están
tiradas y flotando por todas partes y
eso es realmente una pena y por último
vamos a japón donde existe un curioso
tapabocas inteligente llamado enzimas
que tiene conexión bluetooth por lo que
al conectarse a un smartphone permite
amplificar la voz y traducir lo que dice
el usuario a 8 idiomas diferentes además
de realizar llamadas de forma remota
con la mascarilla encendida la
aplicación de celular se puede conectar
a una distancia de hasta 10 metros
y transcribir lo que alguien dice a
texto
también puede traducir lo que has dicho
y reproducirlo en altavoz
así llegamos al final de este espacio
cuídense si es posible quédense en casa
recuerden que la salud es lo más
importante y continúen con toda nuestra
programación en france 24 y france24
puntocom
[Música]